mauvais point pour ce produit dont
l'origine n'est pas assez précise il a
droit à son autocollant pénalisant
viande de nulle part on apprend quand
j'ai bien du port français on informe
aussi quand ça vient d'eux on ne sait
pas ou parce que je n'aime pas spécifié
dans cet hypermarché on se félicite de
l'initiative des agriculteurs pour les
clients savoir d'où vient la viande
c'est bien si elle est français c'est
encore mieux
mais le porte monnaie a souvent le
dernier mot surtout d'où ça vient parce
qu avec tout ce qui se passe avec les
maladies tout ça au on préfère quand
même à savoir l'origine bad romance et
barques et du résultat on essaye de
comprendre quand vous voyez de tels
autocollants de telles affiches vous
changez votre choix
non non parce que là j'ai réussi pour
acheter en promo donc non on regarde
surtout le point chacun a son propre
monnaie je crois les agriculteurs de
châtillon coup l'on souhaite également
sensibiliser les distributeurs dans
toutes les grandes surfaces visiter il
note des défaut d'étiquetage
on a vu qu'il y avait l'éleveur et que
ses vaches en photo
on est incapable de dire aujourd'hui est
ce que c'est réellement une bête qui
vient de là on ne sait pas c'est quand
même triste jour
de produire des bonnes mais lors des
marches allez plutôt constructive nous
on précise aujourd'hui un numéro de lot
apparemment ça leur paraît pas assez
satisfaisants donc je me rapprocher
d'eux pour en savoir plus les
agriculteurs ont épuisé leur stock
d'étiquettes de son ont été collés pour
défaut d traçabilité